Speaker 1: This is kind of it's kind of funny.
It's kind of depressing. On the one hand,
the Post Office, as it is currently operating,
is operating not as well as it could,
thanks to Donald Trump's selection of
Louis DeJoy to be the postmaster general.
Republicans love to attack the post office.
They want to damage the post office and.
And the reason why is to encourage private
industry to replace it. So on the one hand, the
Post Office is functioning poorly because of that,
and Joe Biden can't just replace Louis DeJoy.
Joe Biden has to wait until he can replace
members of the Postal Board of Governors,
and they can then replace Louis
DeJoy. So there's not really that much
that that Biden can do until he's able to do that.
And yet at the same time, reporters are asking
Jen Psaki and Joe Biden, Well, why are packages
going to be delivered more slowly around the
holidays? Here is a reporter yesterday asking that
Jen Psaki exactly that question. Take a listen.
Speaker 3: I can go ahead.
Speaker 2: Let me ask a slightly
similar, different way.
Speaker 3: Sure. Based on everything
being announced today, yeah.
Speaker 1: Can this
Speaker 2: administration guarantee that
Speaker 1: holiday packages will arrive on time?
Speaker 3: We are not the Postal Service or
UPS or FedEx. We cannot guarantee what we can
do is use every lever at the federal government
disposal to reduce delays to ensure that we are
addressing bottlenecks in the system,
including ports and the the need for
them to be open longer hours so that goods
can arrive. And we can continue to press
not only workers and unions, but
also companies to take as many
steps as they can to reduce these delays.
Speaker 1: Now there are people who reacted
and said, No, no, the government is the Postal
Service. It's it's not OK. The Postal Service is
sort of this weird in-between. It's an independent
business enterprise. It's under the purview of the
federal government. But Joe Biden doesn't control
package delivery. He doesn't control what it costs
to get a tracking number. He doesn't control the
logistics of certified mail or anything like that.
It's an independent agency of the executive
branch. And the way Joe Biden can influence it
is by choosing appointees, by appointing people
to the board of directors who then can decide,
Do we want to keep Trump's Postmaster General,
Louis DeJoy or not now? But my best assessment is
that on December 8th, one of Trump's postal board
appointees has their term end. At that point,
Joe Biden can replace them. And it's believed that
that will shift the balance in the direction of
reason, and they will remove Louis DeJoy. But
it's this crazy thing where on the one hand,
they are ignoring the fact that Trump
deliberately kneecapped the Postal Service
through his indirect influence by selecting Louis
DeJoy. That's why things are the way they are now,
not because of Joe Biden. Joe Biden doesn't
get a pick for the board of Governors
until December. But then, on the
other hand, they're asking Jen Psaki,
Can you guarantee package delivery times now? How
could Joe Biden guarantee that? That's that's not
the way the Postal Service actually works now,
whether they are deliberately misunderstanding
that in order to ask these questions to be
salacious and provocative and titillating,
or whether they genuinely don't know that, that's
how it works. I don't know it would. It would be a
sad commentary on the state of journalism if they
really don't understand why the Postal Service is
the way it is right now. And it's because Louis
DeJoy, as postmaster general, he's postmaster
general because of the choices that Donald Trump
made to the Postal Board of Governors. Joe Biden
will get a shot at changing that in December.
But yeah, it's almost like they think Biden's
deciding we're going to slow down package
delivery the way Trump slowed down testing.
They seem to act as if Joe Biden has control,
just deliver more quickly and fix the problem.
I believe this will be solved, but it's going to
take a little bit of time and just just pathetic
questions. Pathetic continued pathetic
questions from the White House press corps